à seulement sept ans will i am est
considéré comme un véritable héros alors
que comme chaque semaine le jeune garçon
d'or chez sa grand mère dans les
yvelines
il est réveillé en pleine nuit par un
bruit suspect dans la chambre de sa
mamie inquiet il se rend compte que la
lumière est allumée et découvre la femme
allongée sur son lit qui tient un
discours confus et prononce des mots que
le jeune garçon n'arrive pas à
comprendre
victime d'un infarctus elle est en fait
en détresse respiratoire très vite sans
céder à la panique il se précipite sur
le téléphone est alors et flex
incroyable de composer le 18 quelques
minutes plus tard les pompiers alertés
par le jeune garçon se rendent sur place
et parviennent à prendre en charge la
victime attend un acte héroïque que les
forces de police ont souhaité honorer en
remettant jeune garçon la médaille de la
sécurité publique des yvelines
une belle histoire comme on aimerait en
entendre plus souvent
[Musique]
non
williams
sept ans
alors je voulais remercier sa maman
laurence d'être avec nous ce soir vous
avez dit chez la dernière interview que
fait williams après il faut qu'ils
reprennent une vie normale voilà un ça y
est c'est bon et en tant que classe on
willy est chiant s'il vient c'est ça va
tu travailles bien tranquille qu'à une
fiancée mais pour en tout cas
un réunion il est mignon paru merci
d'être avec nous tout cas alors c'est
incroyable cette histoire puisque
lamhamid williams qui s'appelle simone à
la 68 ans et c'est là donc la maman de
laurence est la fin la facture suivie
d'un arrêt cardiaque
comment va simone déjà la famille se
remettent doucement les médecins disent
qu'elle est elle va elle va se sentir
mieux dans les prochains jours qu elle
en espère d'accord pas trop se prononcer
on voit là d'accord très bien elle se
remet doucement en tout cas c'est ce que
vous nous avez dit alors c'est vrai que
comment se sont passées les
retrouvailles entre williams et sa mamie
parce que ça devait être fou ça ah oui
non c'était vraiment bas riche en
émotions parce que pour le coup la mamie
dès qu'elle l'a vu arriver ces théories
cerruti sauveteurs voilà c'était
vraiment magique et puis bon bah les
larmes dans les yeux
des remerciements williams comment s'est
passée ta paniquer ou tu t'es dit il
faut que je faut que je vienne en aide à
ma grand mère commençaient à une
question juste oui et c'est sa maman qui
t'avait appris à comment appeler des
secours aux 45 le problème c'est ça hein
c'est sahel t'avais dit si un problème
tu fais ça et tu l'as fait tout seul
j'avais retenu le numéro way formidable
c'est incroyable alors c'est vrai que
vous faisiez vous qui l'avez appris vous
lui avez dit si un souci si jamais un
souci un jour avec mamie
il faut appeler les pompiers tu fais le
18 sur le téléphone et aura un
interlocuteur est hélas on ne posera un
tas de questions il faudra savoir
répondre alors on t'a posé comme
question williams a su répondre à toutes
les questions telles tu leur as dit quoi
à ya des questions que je n'ai pas su
répondre oui tu leur as donné ton
adresse adresse où tu étais tu la
connais ici mamie à ce moment là
n'étaient pas encore en arrêt elle l'a
aidé à jack adresse et après
malheureusement elle était en arrêt
cardiaque dont elle n'a pas pu faire la
suite
et du coup vers l'entrée téléphonie 18
oui mais une fois que tu vas les
pompiers vosgiens pas je leur ai dit ce
qui s'est passé et j'y arrivais pas un
vrai rapport parce que c'est ça tu
arrivais pas ou à la porte quand les
pompiers sont arrivés
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors qu'est
ce t'as fais pas je raconte la cuisine à
main à 43 par la seconde à présent vers
la porte serait occupée incroyable et
comme vous avez appris ça comment vous
après ben en fait on m'a réveillé à 3h
du matin puisque ça s'est passé vers
12h30 et du coup on m'appelle en pleine
nuit
oui il faut venir chercher votre enfant
parce que votre maman a fait un malaise
il ya les pompiers à saint suaire
donc on accourt et puis bah dans ces cas
là bon c'est la panique quand même et je
vois mon petit bonhomme entouré de la
police qui était la sienne ce qui est en
train de gérer qui lui alors toi tu es
là à l'arrière à tout gérer toujours été
plutôt calme plutôt serein et puis et
puis après les poules les pompiers et la
police m'ont dit qu'ils avaient vraiment
été quoi je crois qu'il s'était vraiment
vous pouvez apporter ta rechute a reçu
une médaille paris est à ramener la
médaille louis joly est libellé meyers
était fier d'avoir quatre médailles 1
et il paraît qu à témoigner devant ta
classe de ce1 aussi alors à raconter
toute l'histoire d'un héros dans ta
classe c ça maintenant pour les fit
était le héros
tu sais toi aussi tu as héros mais c'est
vrai que c'est important parce que même
dès le plus jeune âge de savoir
voilà peut-être voile afin d'avoir les
gestes simples les pompiers de 18 le
samu le 15 où il avait appris tout ça
est principalement les coups bas sur les
pompiers il fallait pas pour obtenir non
plus bravo à la maman aussi d'avoir eu
le réflexe bien sûr il ya votre enfant
tout petit si l'ex passe quoi que ce
soit je trouve ça le 18 alors je
voudrais quelqu'un ça peut arriver à
n'importe qui on n'est pas l'abri
d'avoir de faire un malaise
bien sûr pensent en bonne santé donc
voilà je me suis toujours dit que voilà
si jamais mon fils un jour est tout seul
avec moi ou avec sa maman elle vaut
mieux lui apprendre les lettres voilà et
eybens et william en tout cas je suis
fier de toi mon chéri merci faire de toi
tu vas devenir pompier lui faire quoi
plus tard soit médecin lequel veut voilà
il doit aider les gens il veut sauver
des vies peut pas travailler avec moi
non
[Musique]
[Rires]
m
on peut le garder avec nous alors